So what now?
Well, if you're
an IOS Developer Nanodegree student,
hopefully you've submitted your app for
grading.
And maybe you got feedback, or
maybe you're still waiting.
Either way, you've almost graduated and
that's really exciting so
congratulations.
There's just a couple more things
that you need to do before doing so.
If you've developed an app that
you'd like to make a business out of
I will bring your attention again to
the Udacity Entrepreneurship
Management Nanodegree.
Which will take you through the process
of making your app profitable.
There's a link to it in
the instructor notes below.
If you've posted your
app to the app store and
you're just interested in monitoring
feedback and making it better
there's some instructions for doing so
in the reading notes that follow.
Whatever your path,
this is where I leave you.
And I hope that you have had as much fun
taking this class as I had making it.
And I seriously cannot wait
to see what you guys build.
So, until next time.